I think out of anyone I've ever met
you've had the most interesting side
quests in Japan the stories you tell
yeah I've had well I've mentioned you
need to supplement your income so if you
would I mean you could surely tell some
of the stories they don't if this isn't
a movie some of the stuff that you got
up to in Japan everyone would be like
this is the stupidest movie ever made
may it would be it would be the
stupidest movie ever made why did anyone
do this I mean I've had so many random
jobs I my first one that I can remember
doing beside I worked for NHK for a
while that was kind of cool how did that
all come about so I found an
advertisement or someone told me that
they you know it's an open call and it's
a show where they have like eight to ten
foreigners and they're all from
different countries and they say like
today's theme is something Japanese it
could be like in toes and then they send
three of the foreigners out on location
somewhere and they experience a
different kind of Bento maybe this is
the most expensive one maybe this is the
most beautiful one
um and then we talk about like ubuntos
in America dude would never work because
there's no Burgers
yeah but like it was tough because you
had to represent the entire nation right
of America that's an overwhelming power
and so I get to say all the opinions and
then be like well if they're right or
wrong it doesn't matter but you have to
be very careful you just say things like
as far as I know bone in is best and
then you need to have like I'm just
saying as an example as an example tell
me how you really feel bone in is best
so but yes
um that's all of America's opinion don't
worry yeah on behalf of me
so it was that kind of job was cool
because I gave you you know a couple
hundred bucks a month and you get to be
on TV and since I was a theater
background it did Keep Me connected with
like oh this is exciting this is yeah
this is yeah performing entertainment
yeah I I didn't hang my hat on it
thinking like I've made it you know but
like it was a cool thing and then I I
got to be an extra in a movie in Japan
which was awesome it was called
Vancouver
and uh it was a baseball movie and I um
the sunrise of Vancouver the sunrise of
Vancouver and it was like a uh it was
set in like 1920 and I I was like in the
I went to the costume things we went out
some field in the middle of God knows
where a side Tama or something and they
were like
uh Peter Davis I was like Macy they're
like okay
I was like all right that'll work and
then he was like uh you're like the last
guy and they were like well we have is
like a medium and you're more of an l
and I was like oh so like the jacket
like didn't fit and I it like scrunched
on I look like homeless and I so I was
like no I'll give my character like a
you know like some backstory yeah I'll
give him like a name and I and his name
was Chester Flint it was a cool name but
um and then I I was you know I was
getting into it and I decided all of my
scenes took place at like a bar so I I
just always made sure that anytime they
said action I was like the lowest one on
the table kind of like barely just like
drinking as much as and if ever there
was food placed in front of me Chester
always needed like a little bit of
because he didn't know his next meal was
coming so I had like the best night ever
for like two days I got to eat and drink
for free although it wasn't beer it was
like just flavored water but I I went
all in on that character and I thought
you know I think I've got a real career
here uh no did not but like that was
still cool because I got money for it
yeah hell yeah and right as I was coming
back from that I had I had booked with
an agency somehow
and they said we have this audition for
you to be a a model for a furniture
company called okamura okay that's a
legit furniture company I was like I was
like yeah sounds cool man and I go there
and again just like the baseball film
they had the wrong name they were like
are you the cameraman and I was like oh
no I don't have any equipment and
they're like [__] it you're in and uh it
was me and about 35 French models who
were like six two and jacked like I'm
talking perfect bodies yeah and I was
like all right this is so bad I'm this
is so awkward and we had a group
audition and I was like the last guy
there was four of us in our group it was
three French guys in me and we had to go
up it's like the top where the okamura
you know sales
presidents were waiting yeah and I
remember the French guy didn't hold the
door open for me it kind of like slammed
into my foot and then I put and then I
knocked over this plant and this dirt
went everywhere and I was like I'm so
sorry and they're like it's okay and I
was like I'm starting to feel nervous
I'm starting to feel like
I don't think I look right for this job
I feel like it's all bad and we sit on
these stools and they said you know just
introduce yourself and the the French
guys were like in perfect Japanese they
were just like saying like I've been
modeling for six years I've worked with
you know uh Gucci and Prada and all
these things and then they get to me and
I'm like hi I was uh I like hamburgers
and baseball and I I was in a movie
recently called it's not out yet but
then they were like okay this guy and
the you know the sales staff is kind of
watching me and taking a note and
they're like see why is he here and um I
I was like okay just you got this man
just you know keep being funny keep
being you yeah and they were like now we
just want to see you guys talk to each
other and you can have like a moment
where we're just seeing you guys move
naturally through the thing and I was
like okay so I turned to talk to the guy
and he immediately starts talking to
like his French buddies like just the
three of them and I was like
I took French a little bit and I was
like I was like and then they kind of
just totally ignored me yeah and I
turned back and I was looking at the
sales staff and I was like I'm sorry man
I don't think I'm actually supposed to
be here and he was like you said you
like baseball and I was like yes I do he
was like what team do you like and I was
like yeah cool swallows are kind of a
fun team because they've got the uh The
Umbrellas he was like that's my favorite
team and so we started talking and I
know yeah I ended up getting the job to
be a model for okamoto hell yeah so I
was so awesome
[__] you guys I was you know they they
must have gone back to Gucci and Prada
the thing was we had to take a
shinkansen from Osaka it was my first
time taking a shinkansen I was so
nervous I could not even sleep the night
before right I was just like of what
modeling oh I mean look I thought you
had the chance
no no but like I was so nervous about
this opportunity because it paid a fair
amount of money and I was like oh my God
this is why am I modeling I was like
what possible reason would they and I go
there and it's it's like this really
beautiful woman and like this really
handsome guy and then I'm there as well
and they're like your clothes were over
here and it was like this really tight
yellow Polo that was kind of see-through
and I you could see like you know like
my belly button and I was like feeling
like oh [__] this is so awkward and I
walk out there with like my chinos and
shirt and they're like oh we might need
to do some changing of the shirts and I
was like yeah yeah it's fine though and
they were like is that how you like your
hair and I was like uh I don't know you
know I'm like so I I realized in almost
every scene that I was in I was either
at the back and they always instructed
me that like I couldn't get the fax
machine to work or I'm walking past like
a window with like dropping folders and
so all of my character was like oh God
hires idiots too and I and I was like
well do I have like a cool part where
I'm like at the you know the office
chair and I'm like I have like a cigar
and I'm I'm doing like a business deal
and they're like no no that's these guys
you're gonna be like serving coffee or
you spilled it on yourself and I was
like damn this is fun
I I had to take that and I I parlayed
that into a a job where I was a Model A
second modeling where this one was for a
punching bag so you could buy that at
Don Quixote it was um I still have a
like the blow up ones yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got I was on that one and I'm
like well you're on the box yeah yeah
I'll I'll bring it here you guys can put
that on the floor oh yeah at the very
bottom but so like that one was cool
because they brought this girl from like
the Ukraine and she was like absolutely
the most beautiful person I've ever seen
and she was like I have 200 jobs in
three days let's make it quick and I was
like I was like wow this is so sick I'm
like a real deal and they were like all
right so uh you're gonna be like you
know holding her back she's like
aggressively punching this bag and she
felt really uncomfortable like not
because of me I hope but uh
she's like don't touch me you know what
I'm like I don't know but they said
she's really not getting the look can
you go in there and just gesticulate
like your her job so she can see what it
looked and I was like yeah that's fine
so I got to do like two jobs for once
and then when we finally got it I gotta
say the final product she looks great I
look really stupid but uh they combed my
hair like super to the side and I need
to see this picture yeah it's like four
different images on the box and uh my
students would find it at Don Quixote
and they'd be like
and I was like no no Zen's in Chicago I
don't know that man
I don't know who Peter is then um
so much about it's it was tough